with a lot of exchanges we had the
commissioner
for the last one hour and a half with
the three in important initiatives but
right now this is a very important point
for us on the agenda it's a hearing on
Uber files lobbying and workers rights
and what is important is that this this
house the European Parliament and our
committee the employment and social
Affairs committee
attaches great importance to the role of
whistleblowers in preventing detecting
and Reporting irregularities and
misconduct of businesses and public
entities alike we recognize that
whistleblowing based on the principles
of transparency and integrity is
essential for the good functioning of
our democracies the parliament has stood
in the past and it's still staying
together and standing for this this
particular help that we can get from the
whistleblowers as you are aware in June
2020 to thousands of documents the
so-called Uber files were leaked to a
British newspaper by Uber Chief lovis
those documents suggest that between
2013 and 2017 Uber aggressively lobid
high-ranking politicians to delay or
block legislation meant to regulate the
labor and social rights of Uber drivers
and obstructed enforcement procedure to
the possible detriment of their driver's
right on the 8th of September 2022 our
committee Co
ccided to hold a hearing on Uber funds
the aim of the hearing just to be very
precise is to give an overview of the
situation of overdrivers in Europe and
show to what extent through Uber's
lobbying activities their workers rights
have been affected across Europe within
the scope of existing labor and social
rights
empowering and protecting people and
making inclusive the reality in Europe
is at the heart of our committee's work
and preoccupation especially now in the
context of rising cost of living and
Accelerated Green and digital transition
as our labor markets undergo exteriority
changes our members continue to put
great emphasis on Fair working
conditions and the right of workers
including practical workers I'm
therefore very pleased to welcome Mr
Mark McGann former head of public policy
in Uber and whistlebore I would also
like to welcome commissioner Schmidt who
will also intervene in the first panel
just a few words about the second panel
the second panel we will hear from other
experts Dr Andrea Anastasia assistant
professor faculty of arts and social
sciences maastrich University Rahim Ben
Ali former Uber driver and founder of
Uber drivers Trade union and Miss
Susanna puchikova director of EU public
policy Uber in order to have a
comprehensive view of the situation Uber
drivers in Europe before I open the
first panel I would like to make a
general remark about the conduct of this
hearing we would like to hear from all
our guests all guests are welcome I'm
aware that this topic of that we are
discussing today is one of is one that
many of us are feel strongly about
nevertheless I would like to ask you to
to show respect to all participants as
well of the committee and the house and
it's my duty as a chair to be sure that
this rules will be taking care of and
respected without further Ado I would
like to thank again and to give the
floor to our keynote speaker Mr Mark
McGann please you have the floor uh 10
minutes
thank you
good afternoon
I would like to thank the the
chairperson
and all the members of the European
Parliament committee on employment and
social affairs
for inviting me here to answer the
committee's questions
members of the European Parliament
I have been at the Nexus of industry and
government for almost 30 years
persuading successive generations of
governments legislators and regulators
to enact or modify laws to facilitate
business and economic growth
I lobbied governments around the world
to get Uber what it wanted
in order to succeed
today I'm here to call on the European
Parliament to defend the interests of
drivers and platform workers everywhere
I hope that my testimony today will help
you to better understand
why giving disproportionate power in
legislation
to huge Tech platforms risks
shattering the social justice that this
body fought very hard to establish and
defend
if to paraphrase
democracy is about protecting the
powerless from the powerless from the
powerful
then I believe respectfully it is time
to rebalance the scales in this
legislative debate
now platforms such as Uber were and
remain a fantastic idea
harnessing telecommunications and
software Technologies to make life in
cities and towns more efficient
in terms of getting around with
affordable safe transport Uber brought
about the changes that were long overdue
by forcing its way into cities
it's true that Uber helped to bring
about consumer Choice competition and
quality of service
now in the early days of the mission
at Uber we were
inebriated by the thrill of that mission
funded by unprecedented amounts of
investor money we believed in the
mission and we actually felt it was
something quite Noble
in what we were doing
we were sincere when we told drivers
that they were the backbone of the
company
and Central to its success
we treated drivers like Heroes because
they were our heroes
in those days
we also share the wealth
we gave them expensive iPhones and
showered them with hundreds sometimes
thousands of Euros in bonuses
if they couldn't afford to to buy or
lease a car we negotiated preferential
deals with banks and car manufacturers
we did the same with insurance companies
we gave driver drivers a status that
many hadn't experienced before we told
them that they were part of the team
as taxi drivers took to the streets to
defend their incomes
we told drivers to ignore them just
Uber on
when politicians tried to stop us or
slow us down
we co-opted democracy Itself by
leveraging consumers political power
putting very public pressure on elected
officials to back off
drowning them in millions of Rider
petitions
we told politicians that we would agree
to stop the controversial illegal Uber
Pub service
if they changed the law in the way that
we wanted
weaponized our drivers
and weaponized our customers
they were ours to use
in the service of the mission
governments and politicians just needed
to get out of the way
our driving Mantra was due whatever it
takes
ladies and Gentlemen even in those days
we had
disproportionate power
the dream started to sour in 2015 the
company was growing at Breakneck speed
and we just didn't have time to deal
with drivers in person anymore
we opened huge back Office Centers to
handle drivers concerns by messaging
through the app
we actually grew wary of the very
drivers that ensured the platform's
success
when we found out the drivers were
seeking to organize among themselves
the company used fake identities to
infiltrate their Facebook and WhatsApp
groups to monitor what they were
planning
we constantly revised and improved the
algorithms
that were increasingly directing and
managing the drivers and removing most
human interaction
from early 2014 we faced class action
lawsuits from drivers who were already
challenging their self-employed status
now those those lawsuits forced us
internally into
exhausting linguistic and semantic
gymnastics
the legal team instructed everyone to
use the term partner drivers not our
drivers policy team was ordered to talk
about creating economic opportunities
on no account should anyone use the word
job on no account should anyone use the
word employment we promised the French
government that we would create 70 000
entrepreneurs in Paris alone
if they would radically simplify
the rules for professional drivers
Uber didn't create a new type of worker
as much as find new ways to avoid the
costs and responsibilities that
employers have towards their Workforce
if it walked like a duck if it quacked
like a duck then our Instinct was to say
it's a duck but no the management in San
Francisco said it's not a duck it's a
hamster call it a hamster
we told everyone what we knew they
wanted to hear to investors we
guaranteed unprecedented profits over a
very short time span we told customers
that they could get a brilliant private
transport service at the push of a
button no waiting no hassle cheaper than
any alternative
we told drivers that they could make a
decent living earning thousands of Euros
a month with the status of being their
own boss everybody wins
that was never going to happen
for a business model to succeed someone
in this case would have to suffer it
turned out
we had sold people a lie government
the media
and especially drivers
in those days we were permeated by a
sense of self-entitlement we were right
everyone else was wrong
the response to every problem was Uber
on don't ask for permission just launch
local resistance Uber on drivers getting
fined Uber on cars getting impounded
Uber on drivers getting arrested
get them a lawyer an Uber on violent
resistance from taxi drivers
call the media and Uber on lawsuits
against drivers hire more lawyers and
Uber on
our employees are uncomfortable with our
appetite for risk there is the door
it was always a given that we would
increase the commission that Uber took
from each trip it was always a given
that we would withdraw the so-called
driver incent incentives the subsidies
which allowed Uber to undercut the price
of taxis and other competition once a
city was successfully launched
managers were instructed to very quickly
reduce the spending on subsidies it was
a company-wide campaign called burn the
burn it was ladies and gentlemen the
very definition of price dumping
when we stopped the inventive in the
incentives we then look for new revenue
streams we added a safe ride fee for the
customer although we were saying that
this was the safest way to get around
your city we are we invented the service
fee for what we were already saying was
the best service in town I don't believe
that any of these new revenue streams
actually went to drivers
now for a long time after leaving Uber I
struggled with how life for drivers and
delivery workers appeared to be changing
for the worse
The Tipping Point for me and the reason
I'm here today was an Uber trip I took
in Malaga in the spring of 2021
during the trip
being Irish and very chatty I started
talking to Omar the second General
generation Moroccan he was explaining
how difficult it was to find work on the
platform he would have to spend most of
the day waiting in his car to be
connected with a ride now he was
positive about Uber but he missed the
early days when he was treated as part
of the team and made to feel part of the
company's success these days he said
there was no human interaction and he
had a lot of difficulty getting anyone
to respond to his concerns
I spent almost an hour he drove me for
almost an hour and it cost me 32 euros
I asked him about his earnings how much
was he actually going to take home
he said well Uber will take the
commission of 25 they'll then very
responsibly
for once pay the vat to the Spanish
government
and then he had to pay for the leasing
of the car he had to pay for the petrol
the parking cleaning insurance he
calculated that he might get seven euros
for that one hour ride
barely the minimum wage
now when the Uber files were published
in July Uber said and I quote driver
earnings in the U.S UK Italy France and
Spain are at or near
all-time highs
I would encourage the members of this
committee to ask for the source data on
which such claims are based I know
better than anyone how easy it is to
produce and manipulate such such data
that supports your messaging
when I was at Uber we paid academics to
use skewed data sets
to produce numbers that favored Uber's
position
the data would show high earnings
because the data didn't take into
account the time that the drivers were
waiting between one trip and another
the drivers sorry the data would show
that the drivers wanted to be
independent but based on very carefully
designed driver surveys as Mark Twain
famously once wrote there are ladies and
gentlemen
lies damn lies and statistics
I think for so many platform workers
around the world and in Europe like Omar
the dream has soured
despite being applauded as Heroes during
the pandemic drivers and delivery
workers are clearly insufficiently
heroic to receive a decent living wage
health insurance paid leave
minimum protections that were once
considered so sacrosanct in this
European Union
platform companies that deny their
Workforce basic labor rights in the name
of a zealous stubborn libertarian belief
that flexibility is what workers value
most are being dishonest with
governments misleading with investors
and in the harsh Economic Times in which
we live cruel with millions of workers
the workers on Whose backs their
businesses were built
my view is that when human capital is
Central to your commercial success you
would better find a way to ensure that
your business model works for all your
stakeholders including your workers
otherwise sooner or later your stock
price is going to hit the bottom now I
know that the committee is debating
legislation on improving working
conditions and platform work Central to
the commission's draft is the
presumption of employment
a presumption that I believe would reset
the balance between the powerful and the
powerless by putting the burden on the
company to show that the the worker is
truly independent is truly an employee
or is truly independent I should say so
the presumption of employment versus the
presumption of Independence
a presumption of employment strikes the
right balance it's a balance that still
allows the flexibility for those who
want it while shifting the cost of that
flexibility to The Entity the benefits
the most
the company
in this legislative debate power and
influence I believe are
disproportionately skewed towards the
interests of the big Tech platforms
I know that better than anyone I was
part of that powerful lobbying Machinery
now I still believed that well-organized
transparent lobbying is a fundamental
component of a healthy parliamentary
democracy
it should be of concern to any Democrat
however when you reach a point in a
legislative debate where the balance of
power is so heavily tipped in favor of
one side over the other
that may be the case in this debate
when tech companies have
disproportionate Financial Resources to
push their message at the expense of the
far less powerful workers on whom their
model is built
there is something truly undemocratic
happening
that's why I'm here today
I have a voice
and therefore I have a responsibility to
help fix what I help to break
disruption can be creative but it
doesn't have to be disruptive
human decency is not a zero-sum game
Margaret Atwood once wrote
better
never means better for everyone
it always means worse for some
respectfully it falls to this committee
to this Parliament and the member states
to ensure that Tech Innovation and
platform work can mean better for all
thank you for allowing me to contribute
to your work
[Applause]
thank you very much for your testimony
Mr Megan
um
I would I would like to invite right now
um the commissioner for jobs and social
rights Nicola Schmidt for
um his intervention please commissioner
thank you thank you very much I must say
it's a very important meeting
it was quite impressive your speech
and I think it's also a very important
meeting in a way how our democracy is
functioning in that way I think uh
it is for this Parliament
a very very important contribution to
European transparency and European
democracy so I'm very very grateful for
for what you have said
now just to give you a a sharp a rapid
overview
from my uh my my position and also to uh
to be transparent how we dealt on this
file because uh when we started this
commission it was in our in my mission
letter to work on the fair working
conditions for platform workers that was
in my mission letter
and I must say I took this very very
serious as many many of you did also in
this Parliament
now
um
the commission has been assessing the
matter of fewer files
and they are a certain number of issues
connected to what you have said also who
are connected with former members of the
commission
and here at Olaf's request it has also
shared the commission has shared
information
relevant to the Mandate of Olaf
and as a general rule Olaf analyzes all
incoming information of potential
investigative interest
according to their standard procedure
and in agreement with Olaf we invite the
parliamentarians who want so to be in
touch with Olaf for any further
information on specific issues which
have been mentioned also in the Uber
files
the commission's proposal for a
directive on improving working
conditions in platform work
we consider it to be a game changer and
I think you describe the reality
of the work of many many many platform
workers
yesterday I was in Paris and I had the
opportunity to listen to more than 100
platform workers describing to me the
real situation of platform workers
and the idea well we are creating jobs
whatever kind of jobs
whatever precariousness whatever low
salary it's a job is a wrong totally
wrong alternative what we are striving
for is good jobs Fair jobs with fair and
decent pay
and I think it is possible for platforms
to be in this logic of good jobs
and that's the aim of our proposal
and I must say that this Parliament
adopted a report
some months ago on platform work
with a large majority
and I must say that we were very much
inspired
in our draft proposal by this report on
platform work
because it is a good report by the way
and it goes absolutely in the right
direction
now when we when you work on such
an important piece of legislation
as uh the the directive on platform work
is because it is a central element of a
new business model and you describe this
business model which is disruptive
indeed
Innovative indeed but has led also to a
lot of social abuses it is normal that
you have before drafting such a proposal
it is normal that you have
an extensive exchanges with all
stakeholders
and it is true I was approached by
platform workers as I was approached by
platforms themselves to discuss about
the content of this piece of legislation
so it is usual practice to engage with
representatives from all the sites from
all stakeholders including also Civil
Society
uh to have this kind of dialogue and to
be I would say in a listening mode
we exchanged with the range of
stakeholders
meaning business associations platform
companies platform workers associations
trade unions member states
Representatives experts from Academia
and international organizations
but also not only European but also
coming from other parts of the world and
we know that there are issues also in
other parts of the world and as I always
say California the place where finally
the the platform economy was invented
was also the place where at I think at
the first legislation was invented to
bring Platforms in a normal frame
socially speaking mainly
so the commission was in contact with 28
digital labor platforms including Uber
for organizations representing platforms
and 24 organizations were presenting
people working through platforms
in September 21 the commission held two
consultation hearings with platform
workers associations and platform
companies to inform the commissions to
inform about the commission's initiative
25 associations and 25 platform
companies were invited covering various
sectors of the platform economy
moreover the European social Partners
have been consulted through two
treaty-based consultations in line with
article
154. we listened carefully to all the
stakeholders and we considered their
concerns and Views which were often
going into different directions
well the interests are not the same on
different sides As We Know
drawing from these extensive
consultations the commission has adopted
and ambitious yet balanced proposal for
a directive last December to improve
working conditions in the platform
economy ensure a Level Playing Field and
supported sustainable development
and I've always repeated it's now aim is
not to destruct or to destroy platforms
or to make life for platforms impossible
in Europe because platforms respond also
to new way of life to new demands in our
society but you cannot build a business
model on a social regression on enduring
the social guarantees which have been
established all over during decades and
decades so I think the the issue of our
proposal is precisely to guarantee the
real social protection you mentioned and
at the same time the functioning of
platforms which is absolutely possible
because there are platforms giving the
right social protection
decent decent wages to their workers and
nevertheless survive what they are
complaining about is that they are in an
environment environment where
competition is not loyal because some
are not following this example they try
to find finally undermine the normal the
normal schemes the normal rights in
order to guarantee uh a competitive
advantage
well I think that this is a very
important moment because we are living
in a time where the work of the light
the world of work the organization of
work is at stake
and we have to make sure that Europe
which is an example an example and I had
the opportunity to talk to a certain
number of non-european Labor ministers
including the American the U.S labor
Minister and they look at Europe they
want to know what we are doing and I
think we have already in many areas
indicated how we have to bring things
into the right shape especially in the
digital economy which is a new area and
this is also a challenge for us and
thank you very much for your explanation
for your openness your transparency and
your courage thank you
foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much commissioner I would
like to open the floor for the
employment coordinators or their
representatives for asking their
questions I would kindly ask to to keep
the interventions uh at two minutes and
then we are going to have two minutes
reply so I will start with the Epp Group
Dennis Rod kpb coordinator please
foreign thank you very much dragos
well dear mark thank you very much first
of all for your visit and I would pay
tribute to you for your courage I think
this has really shed a lot of light and
it's really highlighted the work that
we're doing in the regulation of
platform work it's playing an important
contribution to that because it makes
clear what we're dealing with and I
think we've had the buzzwords mentioned
and Nicholas Schmidt mentioned them as
well you talked about human dignity the
dignity that is of the driver and
Nicholas Smith mentioned the potential
of a game changer
I'm Resolute here that we need to move
things forward
on this topic
because I think notice against the
platform economy quite the contrary
Nicholas you yourself said there is
potential here
are new opportunities for people to earn
money via a platform without losing
rights and without trampling people and
dignity underfoot I think that's
Elementary but those models that only
work commercially because they injure
the Dignity of people and don't take
into consideration human needs is not
something we can tolerate now I'd like
to pick out some individual points
you will have then to decide if you wish
to come back on them first of all could
you say something about the insurance
companies uh interest uh
our Stakes perhaps in the Uber business
model then you mentioned governments now
which government have been particularly
attentive to Uber in recent years
I'd also like to know what lodgy Lobby
agencies have been used by uh Uber in
recent years to bring their influence to
bear on particular decision makers in
the EU and the final question is that
you were talking about fake profiles
being used by drivers to avoid
surveillance on social media what about
the sanctions via the app and algorithms
that run within the app thank you
thank you very much
there will be a lot of questions I would
like I would like to ask you to try to
be as concise as possible to try to
answer as many of them from as many
members so please you have the floor
thank you chairperson
um and thank you
um you asked about insurance
in the early days in 2014 even in 2015
Uber at the time had an insurance policy
from a U.S company which may or may not
have covered
Uber's uh trips in many European member
states however when the insurance sector
saw that ride sharing that passenger
Transportation was going to become huge
they realized that it would be a very
lucrative business for them to get into
so the Uber management negotiated with
various companies including AXA for
example in order to make sure that all
Uber rides were insured drivers and
passengers so it certainly became a big
business for for the insurance industry
you asked me which government was most
attentive I have to say that the German
government was very attentive in saying
no at the time because Uber was
considered to be breaking the law in in
Frankfurt and Munich in Berlin and
Dusseldorf
Etc so
um I can't say in my time that any
specific European government was the
most attentive certain individuals in
certain governments were very helpful
very attentive I think instinctively
what we used to call here the new member
states so the the baltics and the and
the the Eastern Europe countries
understood the necessity to have good
competition and better service but I
cannot point to any single member state
government that favored Uber as a
government again individuals yes full
governments and my time of course ended
2016-2017.
um haradka if I start to tell you which
lobbying consultancies we use at the
time I think we would very quickly run
out of speaking time but I'd be very
happy to work with your offices again
the lobbying was transparent the EU
transparency register exists however it
is still fundamentally flawed since it
does not cover lawyers and law firms and
it doesn't cover investment Banks and
bankers so it still needs to be
rebalanced and finally in terms of the
fake profiles so we had a massive
security team at Uber we paid security
firms private detectives former Secret
Service Personnel in the US in Europe
and Germany in Spain to investigate the
taxi unions the people who owned the
taxi licenses so there was certainly at
the time
I specify at the time I cannot speak for
Uber today but at the time we had a
tendency to go sort of digging in
people's trash cans to find out exactly
uh who was doing what and when we found
out about
the the workers wanting to organize
God forbid not unionize wanting to stand
up for their rights that's when Uber
started to realize that they needed to
keep a lid on the freedom of workers to
actually uh
unionize mobilize and ask for new rights
thank you
thank you very much let me move to the
snd group we have the reporter on the
platform work file uh Elizabeth mini
please you have the four thank you thank
you so much Mr President and thank you
dear commissioner and I really have to
thank you Mr metcan was incredibly
impressed and also very much touched I
have to say by your speech and so thank
you for your courage and your
transparency so um as you know we are
here in this house of democracy
negotiating a very important file so the
directive on platform work and we are
simply focusing on two main issues so
first of all you know to State the
correct statues of workers so if there
is bogus self-employment we just need to
say that that is a bogus and so workers
that are employees have to have the
social all you know of employees so we
are not against the platform economy we
are not against the good employers but
we are against a false uh you know
classification of workers second of all
we are saying that algorithms cannot be
black boxes so you have to be
transparent to give information just
weeks ago in Italy a boy a very young
Rider died and he was dismissed after
being dead he got any the family got an
email after mortem this is middle age
this is not social rights but here there
is I have to say a toxic narrative going
on that we are so to say in
automatically reclassifying workers
which is not absolutely true and it's
simply I mean we just need to read what
is written in the in the last version of
the compromises so so I wonder if this
toxic narrative even spreading and
spreading and going on and going on and
being completely false is somehow
connected in your opinion to you know a
more or less transparent lobbying
activity so I ask you and I close down
do you think that the Uber and lawful
loving practices are still widespread
are still being emulated by platforms
especially on this very important
legislative files thank you thank you
very much
please
foreign
it's very sad what you said about the
young person who died in Italy last last
week and and of course that's definitely
not the fault of uber however
when robots are replacing human beings
the level of insensitivity certainly
goes Sky High you asked me a question
about do I believe that Uber is
continuing unlawful Lobby practices I
think the short answer is I don't know
I know that we had a philosophy we had a
methodology we had almost unlimited
Finance just for 2015 2016 globally on
our policy on our lobbying on our
Communications we were spending 90
million US Dollars this is in the data
and and by the way I should say that
it's not what I think of what I believe
it's what the data shows the data that I
provided to the journalists
um
lawful and unlawful I shouldn't speak to
moral and immoral that's something else
when you're spending millions of dollars
to block legislation that's trying to
give people not fantastic protection but
minimum safety net minimum protection
when you're spending millions and tens
of millions opposing ballot propositions
in California or in Massachusetts to
deny workers their basic labor rights
their basic human rights which so many
of us are allowed privileged to have
when you're spending tens if not
hundreds of millions of dollars or Euros
globally on expensive law firms
to drown workers in legal fees when they
try to seek reclassification as
employees so I am not qualified to talk
about the legality of Uber's lobbying
practices I just think that perhaps some
of this at least for me is borderline
immoral thank you
thank you
um very much we move forward to the
renew Europe group and we have the
coordinator Lucia Doris please you have
the floor yes uh thank you dragos for
giving me the floor and thank you McGann
for being here with us today thank you
commissioner Schmidt to be being with us
today
um I have to say it was wonderful I'm
very sad what we've heard from you Mr
McGann and I applaud you for your
courage in renew we
strongly feel about whistleblowers and
we think that you should be very well
protected and very appreciated for what
you do
most of we what we heard and most of the
information from the leaks documents uh
from The Years 2013 and 2017.
uh show unethical practices and we
believe that they these practices have
to be investigated sanctioned and called
unacceptable for the future
and as you heard today uh from the
previous speakers uh today's debate also
show us how important it is to adopt as
soon as possible a proper and very high
quality directive
because the people who are working
through platforms really need better
working conditions and social protection
and we called on better working
conditions and stronger social
protection for these people through the
Sylvie brunettes report that was adopted
last year with a huge majority in the
plenary and I think it's perfect that
European commission delivered
such a proposal
with the introduction of reputable
presumption of employment relationship
with the triggering criteria
I think that when we are working on the
this directive we have to have in mind
that it's not about Uber it's not only
about it but there are so many other
platforms right
so our goal in renew is really to find a
smart and very balanced approach now I
have two questions on you one is on you
Mr McGann and I would like to know how
transparent was the algorithmic
management
both to employees and to Uber drivers
during your period of time that you
spend in Uber and I also have a question
for commissioner Schmidt you express
concerns yesterday at the direction of
negotiations in the Council on the draft
directive and my question is whether
you're following our negotiations in
European Parliament and what do you
think about the deletion of the
triggering criteria for the presumption
thank you
okay I would like to invite first Mr
McGann to answer please
thank you very much for the questions
and thank you especially for your kind
uh comments with regards to the
protection of whistleblowers and
although no directive in the European
Union is ever perfect I'm privileged to
be able to benefit from the EU
whistleblower directive protection in
terms of the specific question to me on
transparency of algorithmic management
and again I will speak with regards to
the time I was running public policy for
for the company it would be
inappropriate to speak about practices
today
um
companies and I represented some of the
biggest technology companies in the
world who at the time happen to be
European back in in the 90s and the
2000s and there's a very fine line
between transparency and the need to
protect intellectual property as I think
everyone in this in this chamber will
will agree however there were practices
at the time which were questionable
certainly from a European legal
perspective there were the driver
platform application that was the
customer or what we called writer and of
course there was also our Behavior with
our own employees we had technology
called godview which allowed to monitor
any car who was in the car where they
were going and that was technology which
was available to almost everybody in
every office and that was very mature
and the management realized that and
they took steps what I would say uh if
this can be helpful is while New
Management can come in and replace old
management I don't believe that new
management comes in and strips out all
of the engineering that had been done
previously all of the software
advancement so my I guess
my personal opinion is that it's quite
likely that the algorithmic management
today of customers of drivers is
certainly based on the original
platforms that we had at the time there
were debates and actually quite a lot of
fights internally with the US wanting
um customers to to be able to opt out of
new privacy Provisions where our culture
in Europe is to opt in and and that
created a lot of fights between the the
commercial teams and and the European
public policy teams
um and also there were versions of the
application that would when you download
they would
download your contacts book they would
look at what other applications you had
on your smartphone and they would suck
through that data and say to customers
this is in order to
improve the service when in fact it was
about looking at your use of Spotify
looking at your use of other competing
applications so that that data could be
used in order to build new services and
new revenue streams and what we said at
the time and I'll close with this is
Uber is not just an application to get
around your city what you have in your
hand and thanks primarily I would say to
European telecommunications and software
technology what you have in your hand is
this unprecedented
mesh of interconnected people in a city
and once you have them
as your customers once you own those
customers you can sell them anything you
can do anything people will say that
those were the old days of big Tech I
for one don't believe it thank you
thank you thank you very much
um commissioner would you respond to
your question thank you thank you very
much for for this question indeed I
expressed some concern
uh you know our our
directive our proposal is built around
the rebuttable presumption
that's the core of the uh of the uh
proposal
so if you water down if you weaken too
much this central element of the
directive the presumption
then finally your directive loses its
possible impact
that's one of my concerns that the
discussion now in the council is
watering down the idea of the
presumption
the the instrument the tool of the
presumption and that's my major concern
my second concern is
that in our proposal
the uh transparency for algorithms
and the right of people in relation to
algorithms applies to workers
but also has to imply to genuine
self-employed why should a genuine
self-employed not have the benefit of
transparency when we talk about
algorithms they are human beings so they
have the right also to be informed
and I think this is absolutely possible
they in a way work also they are in some
way workers and therefore they should
also benefit from this uh transparency
that's my second concern uh on the
discussion which are going on there's
not yet a definitive report now I'm
obviously also informed uh about your
discussion and I think what is important
for me is the presumption the reputable
presumption which is a balanced approach
but as it was said we are in a world
where there is no balance at all where
those who have the power dominate
absolutely those who are powerless
and therefore this is the right approach
the rebuttable presumption to make sure
that to give the rights to the workers
and to give them also the possibility to
defend their rights because having right
is good but you should also have the
possibility to defend
in a reasonable time you're right and
some
drivers who are here know what I mean
because they know what kind of
difficulty they have or had when they
wanted to get there right also in
relation to jurisdiction so I hope that
the parliament will up to that point and
to have this reputable presumption I
believe that criteria are useful because
that's why we put them into our proposal
and you know the commission always finds
its own proposal
unless the contrary is demonstrated
always the best
um I I all we we all always appreciate
these hedonic uh behavior of the
commissioner I'm kidding uh yes indeed
uh thank you so let's move forward uh
for the for the greens group we have Kim
first Paradox so please Kim thank you Mr
chair
and first of all let me thank you Mr
McGann for coming forward first of all
as a whistleblower to denounce the
practices of uber
um I really think it shows the
importance of the protection of
whistleblowers and also why we as
European parliaments should stand very
firmly for their rights
and I think I want to express this one
more time here breaking the rules is not
Innovation and we cannot have Uber
writing our new rules
and since we have a short amount of time
that's where I'll keep it and I'll dive
delve right into the questions I have
for you uh Mr McGann
so first of all we're the politicians
you lobbied
actually aware that you were violating
labor laws and did they ever confront
you about it
and secondly I I would like to go a bit
further on on the thing you already
mentioned which I find quite shocking
that for example Spotify was being
tracked
um so
in general how did Uber deal with the
Privacy uh of the drivers it was more
collateral data collected
um and and also specifically could you
give some more details on how this data
that was extracted
um was used then and also at which
moments were the drivers tracked were
they only tracks when they logged into
the app or at all time
and my final brief question is on the
assistance to whistleblowers you have
shared the Uber files with the guardian
but did you inform any Public Authority
about the information you had as well
before going to the media thank you
thank you thank you very much Mr mcganne
please thank you thank you very much Mr
attack I don't know if it's because
um you're representative greens but
since you started talking I have bright
sunshine in my eyes
that's the effect of our colleagues so
yeah
so with regards to to
violating of labor laws and and how
politicians confronted us I have to say
in some instances in many instances in
Europe in particular
there was a level of schizophrenia where
we would have transport authorities and
transport ministers shaking their fists
and tell us that we had to stop that we
were illegal you had some economy
ministers who were more open to the idea
of potential job creation
um uh because they were not forbidden to
use the word job we were forbidden to
use the word job uh and and even the
potential for tax revenues new business
models lots of money Changing Hands
um I do remember actually uh sitting
down with uh the then Deputy Prime
Minister of of the Netherlands
um lord of the gasha who said look happy
to sit down and talk to you guys but you
know you're breaking the law and
actually you are jeopardizing uh the
social model of the European Union and
we thought he was old-fashioned and
conservative and and uh maybe maybe it's
because I'm older now I realized that we
were actually part of a problem and not
part of a solution I would also say that
um the labor secretary of the United
States uh at the time in the Obama
Administration told us you have to sit
down and talk to the unions because they
are worried that you are weakening a
model which is already on its knees and
this was uh in the United States so yes
um
certain
governments in certain European
countries did have concerns about labor
laws what was on the front pages was how
we were perceived to be violating uh
transport transport laws
I I can't really say very much
um today unless I pull out my laptops uh
from from those years and talk to you
about the approach to
um how we tracked drivers you know in
the beginning it was very informal
would meet drivers we would log them uh
when the police came knocking on the
door and Don raid our first when we had
the so-called kill switch our first
priority would be to block access to
driver data because we didn't want the
police to get driver's data because then
they would find the drivers and they
would cut us off at the needs it's
interesting that the authorities the
police rarely went after Uber Executives
they provided violating laws then as now
it was always the drivers getting it in
the neck if I can use that that
expression
um but there was clearly as I said in an
answer to a previous question concerns
about drivers being able to do things
that we didn't agree with and we were
able to track their movements we were
able to see where they were were going
when they were offline when they're
online uh and and I have some um
anecdotal data based on the actual data
as to how that maybe have been used in
certain countries in certain cities for
let's say uh nefarious Reasons I'm happy
to to discuss that uh offline in terms
of assistance to whistleblowers so the
directive for those of you who recall it
has a sort of a three-tiered approach
first of all you have strong
whistleblower protection in the European
Union if you blow the whistle when
you're in the company
I resigned three times from the company
because I was clearly unsuited when I
was asking management to sit down and
try and talk to governments find
Solutions rather than just telling
government to get out of the way so
um you know trying to stand up and
disagree with the company culture at the
time at the time
um it was you know don't let the door
hit you on the way out the second tier
of protection in the European directive
is if you go to a public Authority
now I don't know I haven't found a
guidebook for how to be a whistleblower
it's not something that you study for
it's not something that you you probably
and I don't want to be flippant on this
but it's you know who who do you go to
which authority do you go to the police
do you go to
um your local perm rep how do you go to
uh
I mean I have to say to be to be
perfectly transparent and that's what
I'm supposed to do in front of this
parliamentary body I did
um try to blow the whistle twice uh in
the spring of 2020 when the then mayor
of London had revoked Uber's license
because it was considered to no longer
meet the criteria to be a fit and proper
operator I wrote to Merced Khan asking
to come and explain what I knew what
data I had and with the view to trying
to help Transport for London put out
proper rules so that Uber could operate
once more but perhaps have a bit more
respect for for
um for drivers and in the in September
of 2021 I wrote to this committee uh
asking to be heard explaining that I was
feeling
I have to say a considerable level of
remorse because I wasn't some innocent
bystander here I'm no victim I was part
of a system that convinced all of you to
bend the rules get rid of the rules and
let us in
um and I do understand that people have
too many emails but I did write to this
committee uh asking to be heard
explaining that I was uh you know
wanting to share information and wanting
to contribute to the debate it was prior
to the commission's draft directive
which was I think the 9th of December
but it was during your parliamentary
debates here
um and then the last level of protection
which I have to say is very low level
protection if almost no level of
protection in the EU whistleblower
directive is when you go directly to the
media and I was introduced to the
investigations team
of Guardian newspaper uh just after
Christmas I worked with them during
seven months and then icij and
lamond and El Pais and et cetera et
cetera and the rest as they say is
history thank you thank you very much
this is indeed uh one of one of the most
interesting clear debate that we have in
this particular mandate let's continue
though with uh the ECR coordinate and
ECR group lgbia Tara farska please you
have the floor
and Mama
thank you I think there is a collision
of Two Worlds ongoing on the one hand we
have good intentions we have
Declarations of intent
and on the other hand we have aggressive
world of business this is not an equal
battle
you have said that lies were being sold
that it was whatever it takes model
you said that you wanted to maximize
your profits
well obviously that had to involve
exploitation of workers and
reducing the social rights where any
services or authorities interested in
this has anyone reacted I don't want to
point to any countries but it seems
obvious to me that politicians didn't
behave as they should have behaved
while passing legislation
perhaps there was also corruption
ongoing perhaps some politicians were
paid
but we will never know perhaps I I think
that you are being very cautious and
you're weighing your words because we
all know that Uber has an army of
lawyers at its disposal and everyone who
says something that cannot be proven can
be destroyed
it seems that
workers are being
treated
as the weakest links how can the workers
fight if any attempt to get organized is
immediately
repressed how can people get unionized
Uber wants them dispersed Uber wants
them under surveillance and if they
don't like it they should go somewhere
else that seems to be the logic this is
not a free market this is a market where
people are doing bad things and getting
away with it
if we hadn't amended the labor code in
such a way as to pave the way for Uber
we wouldn't have had
the situation which is there now we were
so we were being naive we thought it
would be good for workers and for
customers so was anyone interested was
an authority interest interested could
you perhaps try and answer my questions
thank you very much for for the question
um
you know I was involved in Uber's
activities in over 42 countries
including Poland and I have very fond
memories of working with the teams in in
Warsaw and Dansk in rocklov and
you know if I had heard what you said
now back then I would have said no this
is some sort of conspiracy
but what you say is not a conspiracy
um I have to say that lobbying rules in
the member states and also at the
European level certainly
favored the powerful
over the powerless
I do not believe that anybody was bribed
that there was any Act of corruption if
there was I certainly didn't see it but
nonetheless we had
unequaled unprecedented access to the
very highest level of government in
almost every member state of the
European Union in the European
commission
Etc there was an element of cool okay if
you remember all those years back to the
Lisbon growth strategy Lisbon strategy
for growth and jobs when we in Europe we
thought that technology would be
creating jobs after the financial crisis
I think in 2015 2016 2017 there was
another perception that all of these
cool kids from Silicon Valley with their
new technology-based applications for
services for connecting supply and
demand that would generate this this
highly needed economic growth and job
creation so I don't believe that there
was any corruption
um certainly the methods were highly
unorthodox you know going to governments
and saying here are the facts without
revealing that we'd paid one two three
hundred thousand Euros to academics to
make those facts go in a direction uh to
to to support what we were we were doing
you know we were told and that's what we
said to governments we were operating in
a gray Zone we were told do whatever it
takes and this was absolutely what you
say this was a strategy to put profits
before people to put growth and
profitability before anything else
including respecting the law and the
last thing I would say is you I I know
respectfully say that maybe I'm weighing
my words maybe I'm being careful
I have to say there's before and there's
after when you're a whistleblower so I
cannot take this back
um it's a very difficult thing to do I
have to say it's a very lonely thing to
do
um and it's true that companies like
uber they have so much money to spend on
lawyers to drown you in legal fees and
to shut you up
so think about the drivers
if you go for a presumption of
Independence in this directive it's up
to the drivers to hire expensive law
firms to go to the labor courts to go to
the labor tribunals and wait for years
before somebody has time to say are you
an employee do you deserve minimum no
the financial burden has to be on those
who can afford it which means the
platform companies
um and not on on the drivers thank you
very much
thank you uh thank you very much I can
assure you that you are not alone and
that's actually the spirit and the
legislation that we put forward
um I understand that you you feel lonely
but I can reassure you that this is not
the case and we will stand by you know
so that's quite important
um let me move towards the left group
and we have the Leila shaibi please
tomatoes
again
good evening Mr began commissioner
is this working
I press my button
right
just tell me please reset the clock to
zero
good evening commissioner good evening
Mr McGann and thank you for coming to
speak to us what you had to say was very
strong very powerful
just to you spoke to us about the
philosophy
of uber and it's based on non-respective
law around respective regulations the
use of Lies for pressure on decision
makers so as to influence the law and to
create a law that is in Uber's interest
now as it happens we're currently
looking at the legislation here European
legislation which be of direct interest
to Uber because we'll make Uber respect
their obligations as employers and the
direct that we're proposing here was
proposed on the 9th of December by the
commission commissioner Mr Schmidt we
want to tell you that on a daily basis
we have been getting messages from
platforms and Uber to try and sabotage
this directive
answer my first question to you Mr Magan
is do you think that the social model
European social model with are
protection of workers and social
um models do you think that that is
something that goes against Uber if so
could you give us some examples of
strategies that have been used by Uber
to try and get around and avoid
regulations and labor law you know that
this is a hearing that is getting a lot
of a bit very big audience on the
plastic luxembour there are many people
out there trade unionists who have been
out there since the beginning of the
afternoon with banners calling on MEPS
who are you working for are you working
for lobbyists or are you working for
Citizens I went out to speak to them
before I I came in here and I said that
when we were working for lobbyists were
also work and we're also working against
citizens
so I I hope that your contribution here
today will make us understand better why
we we need to have proper legislation
with regard to all this and this leads
me to my second question in this
Parliament there are some European
members of the parliament who repaint a
little bit apparent-like they preach the
arguments of the platforms platforms who
get together with platforms such as EU
Tech Alliance and others to try and put
pressure on the negotiations that we're
currently carrying out here in the
European Parliament
so when there is a worker who goes in or
tries to gain access they're asked to
leave as I saw last week so if uh the
development of uber means that we have
to dismantle our our social model I want
to know do you agree with me
that when our colleagues are behaving
like this they're not only turning their
backs on workers rights but also uh do
you believe that they're also
contributing in the breakup of our
social model and that they're currently
they're breaking up social justice
thank you let's see
thank you very much for those comments
and for those questions you have been
wondering
you want to know my opinion with regard
to the European social model and if this
is uh
an opponent for who for Uber I think
that we need to look at the messages
from Uber not to you as members of
parliament but to investors and during
the last investors day at the beginning
of the year Uber said very clearly to
these investors and these analysts that
the
model that Uber has is based on the
status of independent workers and that
is the platform on which their whole
that is the base on which their entire
company is based in spite of any rulings
from courts in spite of any uh where
have been carried out by the European
Commission on the workers rights on
these platforms and in spite of any
Democratic decisions in the member
states or in the United States in spite
of the fact that the trend is moving
towards a minimal level of protection
for these workers and it's not something
fantastic they're not going to get rich
overnight but it's just to give them
these basic rights where most rights
that most Europeans are entitled to and
at that time we had three different
messages for three different groups of
people we had for investors we said give
us your billions and you will get a
return on your investment that is
unprecedented for the customers we said
when you take an Uber taxi it's going to
be a high class ride with a personal
driver a chauffeur bottle of water
patience they'll get up and they'll open
the door for you this was the model and
in fact it's also going to be at a a
price that beats all competition
and to drive as we said come and join us
you will have a worthy salary
and people and these people often came
from uh difficult areas of town and we
said no come and join us and you'll be
part of our team so there were these
three different types
of
um groups of people and one of them was
always going to be uh it would come off
worse
and so the whole question of the
European social model this is a
challenge for Uber but if they wanted
immediate Pro product uh profits well of
course this was an opponent but if they
were ready to comply with rights and
laws in countries that they wanted to
operate in and if they wanted to really
build something well then it could be
something that works for them
then the second question
[Music]
um
I'm not a politician even though I
sometimes might seem to speak a lot and
so
uh I do know that you as members upon
Parliament here
you are elected representatives and I
respect that but I was a lobbyist for
Europe with Uber and I know better than
anybody else how to do lobbying with
respect and with transparency
and using
systems where we dilute everybody's
interests into large strong associations
and that's not how democracy works and
so I really would
say that we need to have maximum respect
for members of the European Parliament
maximum respect for those who don't have
a voice and who have to fight to be
heard and the last thing I wanted to say
with regard to the meeting that was
interrupted that you were talking about
if the here in the European Parliament
you can talk in your
native language
that's your right and so thank you very
much merci beaucoup thank you very much
uh we are right now having uh the two
last interventions from our uh
committees that that wanted to to join
us so I have the the pleasure of uh
introducing first the the Tran committee
chair Karima Delhi and then the physics
committee chair Paul Tang I will start
with Karima and then uh Paul uh
duplicate
merciful
thank you sir
I have a question for you Mr mcgahan
you were the chief lobbyist of for Uber
between 20 14 and 2016. you spoke out
about what they were doing in 2013 and
2015 but in 2017 I myself here at the
European Parliament transport committee
we were looking at the fraudulous
methods that Uber was using in with
regard to their influence
and in 2017 in Parliament here we wanted
we did a study on the uh
the share economy in uh transport and
this is the study in fact
this was carried out by a so-called
independent researchers and I do say
so-called independent because within
that team there was a professor
who was a specialist in the area of
collaborative economy but during that
same time he was also Uber's lawyer when
in the city of Barcelona and so in this
study there are 133 times that Uber is
mentioned
um blah blah car which is another
platform very Cooperative only was
mentioned four to one times and that's
just by way of comparison so clearly the
parliament didn't know anything about
this Mr Montero never
spoke about the fact that he was wearing
two hats and it was a two late when we
found out about it but we did think
nonetheless that this was a biased
report because it was a they were using
methods that were are used by uh Thugs
and that has no place in the European
Parliament and what I would like to say
here is even though this is just the tip
of the iceberg that's the first question
and then the second question is are
there other studies and other
institutions that were manipulated and
this really has to do with the illegal
nature of the operation Uber and then
one final thing is it not time for us to
pass legislation on this whole question
of platform
platforms making sure that they respect
the employers rights
and look at this whole question of
collaborative economy because we have
two models because uh Uber always says
that it's a Cooperative economy so that
they don't have to uh comply with all
the rules to do with dignity and
salaries and just finally I just like to
say that as president as chairperson of
the transport committee here in
Parliament there will not be
any
future means of Transport unless there
is the recognition of the individual
drivers uh dignity given around the
floor to potang the chair of the Fisk
Committee in European Parliament poll
please
thank you chair and thank you Mr McCann
for the moving testimony and for the
courage to stand up as a whistleblower
much appreciated and what I take from it
is Uber on at all costs certainly of the
employees
but Uber on also required accomplices
and I would like to focus on that the
first
that comes to mind other Dutch tax
authorities
because I learned from the eBay files
that the Netherlands the Dutch tax
authorities delayed a joint audit on the
request of France Germany Sweden Belgium
in the UK I also learned
that
they shared the Dutch tax Authority
shared information privileged
information with with with Uber that's
one the second one is former
commissioner Nelly Cruz
um she requested to be also with the
president of the commission to be a
commissioner to be a lobbyist that was
declined that was declined two times
um and this is not the first time her
name appears in this conflict of
interest it's the second time that her
names appear so my questions are also
directed at the commission at Nicholas
Smith to let me start there does the
commission investigates whether the EU
rules and especially the directive of
administrative cooperation has been
infringed by the Dutch tax authorities
attached exercise were not allowed to
share private privileged information for
for one thing that's the one thing that
the fisc subcommittee would like to know
also
what is what are the consequences for
Nelly Cruz has she replied to the
request of information by found the lion
and is
the punishment of cutting in the pension
benefit on the table once the
investigation is over and when is the
investigation over
and then to
um those are my questions from Nicholas
Smith and then for uh Mr McCannon
two accomplices the Dutch tax
authorities and Nelly Cruz were they
aware that they were bending their rules
was there sort of
silent understanding that this may not
be according to the rules and that we
were act accordingly to protect them
where the Dutch tax authorities were
where Nelly Cruiser were what is your
impression that's the impression I get
from The Uber Farms but I'm happy to
hear it from you too
thank you very much I will start again
with uh Mark McGann If he if he wishes
to answer the questions of the two
chairs please
thank you uh chairperson
um if I could uh
I would like to answer in the quest in
the language the question was asked
and I would say
that there were a lot of studies with a
great Consultants but some maybe were
more ethical than other than others and
at that time
we had this label we were talking about
the sharing economy the economy of
platforms
The Cooperative economy and we were
trying to shape our identity according
to the mood of the moment
just wanted to add that the European
Parliament itself
also has an excellent Research Center
and I do think that we really need to
stress that that every time that there
is a study and be it uh requested by a
Trade union or a company you have to
look at where the funding comes from
that needs to be more transparent and I
think
that
EU transparency register is very good
but maybe it needs to be better because
you can always get around it if you
don't want to declare that you had a
meeting with such a member of parliament
or a commissioner you can try and get
around it going through maybe some
lawyers or
so everybody's entitled to get to earn a
wage during their living
but when you're working in a democratic
system you need to have full
transparency and you yourself as a
European member of the parliament you
have to make a declaration of your
interests when you take up your position
as a member here in the Parliament and
so I think that you there needs to be a
more harmonization of all these rules
for everybody
uh Mr Tang
complicit
let me tell you who I think was
complicit
the European Union was complicit in
allowing member states to fight against
each other to attract these foreign
companies to locate their operations in
one member State Uber by having a very
sweet
beneficial legal a tax arrangement with
the Dutch government at the time at
least paid 25 corporation tax
on one percent of global profits one
percent
and this is all public information so it
was quite surreal to have the Amsterdam
uh Transportation police
iot coming with Dawn raids coming with
the police dragging off our legal
counsel to jail
um threatening us with cease and desist
letters with with lawsuits when in The
Hague you had other people who were sort
of quite happy to have all this inward
investment and and job creation when I
say job creation I mean the people who
were employed uh at what is the
international headquarters of uber so I
think
um I I think there has to be greater
intellectual honesty within the member
states and perhaps in the Netherlands uh
itself we had amazing access to the
Minister President at the time who
happens to be the Minister President now
and and his staff that was all above
board but certainly we were being
enforced against as an illegal operation
by one part of the Dutch State and
welcome with open arms by another part
of the Dutch State
um you know I I I don't think since
there's an open investigation by Olaf I
don't think it's appropriate for me to
comment uh on any individuals I I have a
great deal personally that's my opinion
of of admiration and respect for former
commissioner Cruz but I'm not competent
to speak to to your question
thank you thank you very much
commissioner Schmidt please yes thank
you very much first I I want to thank
your chair but also
everybody who participated in this
debate and the quality of the questions
and I think
it is a very important that we have this
transparency in uh in European Affairs
because that's an essential element also
of The credibility of the institutions
European institutions now on the tax
issue I unfortunately cannot give you an
answer I I'm not informed about that but
certainly we will check that if there
has been any uh any procedure opened in
relation to this tax issue uh with the
with the Dutch government
on the issue of the investigation
against the former commissioner this
investigation uh conducted by Olaf is
still going on so I cannot comment on an
investigation which is going on it is
very clear that if the investigation
comes to result which shows that the
code of conduct has not been properly
respected then certainly the measures
which can be applied will be applied but
for the time being I cannot say more
because it is still an ongoing
investigation
thank you very much this brings us to
the end of our first panel I would like
to uh thank again Mark McGann for his
amazing testimonial I think it's a
historical moment in the parliament
[Applause]
I would also like to thank commissioner
Smith thank you thank you
[Applause]
um also I would like to to ask for your
patience and let's wait for the second
panel as well it's equally important
um I would I would dare to say that it's
very important to have a balanced view
um and for that uh without uh further
Ado
um I think that we will have the chance
for uh let's say real and independent
academic to take the floor
um I hope that we have connected with us
uh Dr andreana stasse assistant
professor faculty of arts and social
sciences domestic University I apologize
for for the delay but I think that this
the first session was two two important
um and interesting so if do we have
um Dr Andrea anastasa connected
yes it seems so
hear me yes we can hear you we can see
you Professor uh you you have seven
seven minutes we are uh really grateful
to have you uh in this community session
please you have the floor
uh thank you very much
I talked to members of the European
Parliament on this affair of the Uber
files
um I